hello everyone thank you for joining us
today uh to talk about microbial strain
typing for real-time quality control and
Source tracking using ftir spectroscopy
and this is a collaborative presentation
between Brooker and certified group
today and we will be going over how to
use some of the instrumentation from
Brooker to accomplish microbial strain
typing which we do within our group here
at certified group
so just a little bit of background about
me to get started my name is Alex Brandt
I'm the chief science officer with food
safety net Services which is a company
within the certified Group Company
and really I do a lot of functions for
the company here but I started back in
2014
and prior to that I was a graduate
student that did a lot of research with
food production plant environmental
sampling and pathogen subtyping
so a lot of my focus on Research was on
looking at microorganisms in the
environment of the food production plant
and trying to decipher the linkages
between different isolates that we had
found over time
and so when I joined uh fsns and
certified group in 2014 I was brought on
to provide a lot of technical
troubleshooting to customers
with regard to their methods their
results and also their production plant
issues where they had contamination
problems so I still do a lot of that
work now going out to
customers to help them out with issues
and so I can see the value of microbial
subtyping and a lot of that work so
that's really what I want to focus on
with you all today and and show you how
some instrumentation can possibly help
you with that that instrumentation being
provided by broker
so in addition to the work that I do
with customers I also oversee our lab
plus Department
that does contract contract research
work and specialized testing a
significant portion of this specialized
testing that we do is really focused on
microbial subtyping in order to use the
data that we can get from that for
Source tracking and environmental
mapping
fsns also has a software program called
Emma which is our environmental
monitoring software which also helps
with Source tracking so all of this can
kind of go together as one big solution
to help you with finding and
troubleshooting contamination events in
your processing plan
so let's start off uh kind of with some
Basics here so microorganisms include
are actually very complex groups food
products can have very diverse and
complex microbial populations
and these are all influenced by various
things including their primary
production environment so think of
things like Fields farms and feedlots
the processing facility environment
their Packaging Systems the distribution
chain that those boots go through as
well as what happens to them when
they're handled by consumers
so these microorganisms that we can find
in food can include good organisms such
as probiotics bad organisms such as
pathogens and the ones that are just
plain ugly and nasty that we call the
spoilage organisms hence we have the
little graphic here from our good friend
Clint Eastwood's movie The Good Bad and
the Ugly which kind of describes those
different groups that we have in food
products
so you may ask why would I want to track
a microorganism in a food product and
throughout its production chain well
there are many reasons to want to do
that
maybe it's a pathogen and maybe we need
to decipher where it's coming from such
as a niche site in the facility or a
continuous entry in raw material where
that pathogens continually being
introduced into the production process
maybe it's a spoilage organism and it's
spoiling products before their normal
shelf life and we really need to
determine how it's getting onto the
products so it could be some dirty
equipment contaminated raw materials or
various other things that are causing
this spoilage organism to find its way
onto our products
or maybe it's a probiotic maybe it's
actually a good organism and we want to
determine if our starter culture that
we're putting into it
is present in the finished product after
packaging and going through the entire
process
so there's various reasons that we might
want to be able to track these strains
over time and see where they're at in
the process and be able to link them
together
so how do we do this well there are
various subtyping methods or methods
where we are able to look really deeply
at the strain of the organism
and there are a lot of different
technologies that are out there well
there's a lot of technologies that exist
to provide the species identification of
microorganisms from food
however there are many cases where we
need to classify organisms beyond the
species level so we need to know if two
isolates are the same species are the
same or if they're different
so that's where microbial subtyping
Technologies come in and they allow us
to do this differentiation between
isolates
historically a lot of these subtyping
technologies have been DNA based such as
pulse builds electrophoresis which a lot
of people are familiar with are also
known as pfge a lot of people recognize
that acronism acronym
riboprinter
multi-local sequence typing gram LST
people recognize that that acronym quite
a bit as well and whole genome
sequencing or wgs another acronym for
you
uh wgs really uh in the present day is
the gold standard but that takes several
days and it's quite expensive
so there also are some regulatory issues
with uh wgs and using it for subtyping
well one thing that's really a big con
to a lot of people using it is that you
will end up knowing the species of the
isolate and knowing all of its genetic
makeup so that then allows it to be tied
to regulatory agency databases such as
FDA USDA and CDC
uh that utilize databases such as genome
tracker that has other metadata so if
that is out there then you could
potentially be linked uh to a foodborne
illness outbreak
knowing the species is also an issue if
you identify a pathogen so your food
products may not be on hold they may be
in Commerce and if you identify a
pathogen through your subtyping method
that could lead to a recall
in addition knowing all of its genetic
makeup is also an issue because it can
be tied to other isolates and you know
all the virulence factors and antibiotic
resistance profiles
and then if you can as I mentioned get
tied to a regulatory agency database
with metadata in a clinical case you may
be looked at as the source of a
foodborne illness outbreak so a lot of
food industry entities
really avoid using whole genome
sequencing and rely on other methods to
do their subtyping even though it's the
gold standard and even though it gives
you the most information about linking
isolates together
other subtyping methods that are
available that are not whole genome
sequencing such as pfge
riboprinter and mlst
uh however also require you to know the
species or even by conducting them you
will find out the species in the process
of analysis
they don't provide as much information
as whole genome sequencing but you still
get that species information which is
problematic in some cases also some of
these Technologies are limited to only
certain species for example the CDC pfge
protocols only cover about 10 species of
foodborne pathogens so what about all
the rest of the foodborne pathogens what
about the spoilage organisms can't
really use pfge for all of those
and many of these Technologies can be a
multi-day process in some cases
so when uh a few years ago when we were
looking at new subtyping technologies to
bring on to be able to track these
organisms through people's food
processes we identified several needs
and we identified that the needs that we
had were for a system that could one
subtype all microorganisms not just
select species
two perform the subtyping without the
need to identify the species
three performance subtyping without
determining the species in the process
four perform that subtyping quickly
without the need for days of analysis
time
and five perform the subtyping
relatively inexpensively some more
isolates to be run
so we did some investigations and behold
we found the broker IR biotyper
so broker created this technology called
the IR biotyper specifically for
microbial typing and this is really
meant to help with real-time quality
control and Source tracking so that way
you're not taking days to get
information but only a few hours
so when we look at this technology it
was very promising and we have onboarded
it here at certified group and it has
been a very very useful tool for us
so how does it work
well it generates a fingerprint from
microorganism that allows it to be
compared to others it's not a genetic
fingerprint
it uses ftir spectroscopy to actually
measure vibrations of carbohydrate
constituents that are present in many
cell surface molecules such as
glycoproteins and lipopolysaccharides so
again it is not DNA based it's not a
genetic fingerprint is actually looking
at cell surface structures and molecules
and the profile of those that are
present in different strains
so many people may actually be familiar
with ftir and the principle of using it
for material identification such as
foreign materials we actually use uh
infrared spectroscopy quite a bit for
foreign material identification
but this particular application is
actually set up in a high throughput 96
volt format with software that's
specifically set up to do microbial
comparisons
so this is a very important principle
because it allows people to actually
compare organisms without having to
generate data that would be tied to PFE
or whole genome sequencing data that the
CDC or FDA or USDA would have they don't
use this technology for any of their
Source tracking and microbial subtyping
that they do which is a very ideal thing
for us when we looked at this technology
uh also the broker IR biotyper is not
tied to any sort of biochemical
identification information it will not
give you a species identification it's
not a biochemical identification method
replacement
so think of methods out there like uh
the biomerular Vitex which gives you a
biochemical identification this
technology does not do the same thing
and it will not give you an
identification of a species which is
actually good in some cases uh for
instance in the listeria monosetogenes
use case let's look at that
um
in certain uh
types of food products
it makes sense to only look for
listeria-like organisms rather than
looking for Listeria of a particular
species especially monositogenes which
is a pathogen
so this technology allows you to make
comparisons for these listeria-like
organisms without identifying the
listeria species
and this is very important for
regulatory aspects and reacting to
listeria species versus listeria
monocytogenous positives because if you
get a non-pathogenic listeria species so
anything other than almost theory of
monocytogenies it will not necessarily
implicate a ready to eat product if you
actually find a positive but if you have
to identify something to the listeria
monocetogenous level it may cause
product to be implicated and requires
some sort of a rework so this will not
give you that species information for
monocytogenous which is very nice so we
can actually function on just comparing
things as quote unquote listeria-like
organisms
without getting that identification
information but still allowing you to
track those throughout the process that
was one of the key functions of this
technology that we really like
the utility also comes from being able
to test multiple isolates to make
comparisons it's a comparison tool so if
you just test one isolate you're not
going to accomplish too much so you need
to actually have multiple isolates and
even possibly a bank of isolates quite a
few to be able to get good information
out of this
so how does it work it's actually pretty
simple
the first step is to obtain a pure
culture of a microorganism we cannot run
this off of enrichments or off of mixed
cultures so you have to actually get an
isolated organism on a auger plate
the only limitation to this is that you
must be able to take that and make a
homogeneous suspension so any bacterial
organism really that can grow on
non-selective media such as tryptic
soyager blood auger Etc is definitely
possible because we can make a nice
homogeneous suspension of that
we can also do others but we would have
to validate a different growth procedure
such as lactic acid bacteria and Mrs
auger still can be done but we have to
validate a different procedure we can
also use it for yeasts
it's not very optimal for molds because
it's difficult to make a homogeneous
suspension of them between the spores
and the hypey so we tend to try to use
this on things that are you know pretty
basic organisms like we say like yeasts
and bacteria that we can homogenize very
well
uh once we have that pure culture then
we need to streak a plate to make a lawn
so that we have plenty of growth to work
with
so the key to success with this is
ensuring that your growth protocol for
making this lawn plate is very strictly
followed so that re results are
repeatable from one run to the next if
we vary temperatures or media that can
cause things to go out of whack with
regard to the cell structures on these
organisms so a consistent incubation
temperature and time
really is critical so that the cell
surface structure is uniform from one
run to the next
so once we've accomplished this we can
take growth from the confluent area of
the lawn of growth and use a loop and
then put that in a tube to make a
suspension in 70 ethanol this suspension
is made in actually in special tubes
that have metal cylinders in them to
help homogenize that culture so again we
said homogeneity is very important so
we'll Vortex that culture and make sure
it's homogeneous
we add water to this to make the final
suspension and then re-homogenize that
biomass by vortexing again
these suspensions are then spotted onto
a 96 volt graphite plate along with
standards
this plate is then allowed to dry slowly
so that the spots are just solid biomass
and that the ethanol is allowed to
evaporate and during this drying time
you actually can go into all your
isolate information into the software
and set up the run so you know while
you're just sitting there having this go
through the process of drying out you
can be productive and still do other
things such as entering all this
information in
um the isolated information can be set
up then so that isolates from a
particular facility your customer kept
separate
from all the rest in the database that
was another key thing for us we didn't
want uh different facilities icelands
being compared to each other so you can
easily set that up setting them up as
actually as different species if you
want even for different facilities and
different customers that way you can
avoid any kind of crossover when you do
analysis later
we'll then set up the run in the
software with all that isolate
information start to run and then it
only takes about an hour and a half for
a full run of 30 isolates with three
repetitions each so it actually scans us
pretty quickly and gives you data back
pretty quickly as well
so then once all this data is generated
by the machine the computer will
actually Analyze That with hierarchical
cluster analysis or HCA and then you can
look at your data in various ways most
commonly people use a dendrogram for
distance Matrix that you can then export
in the PNG format there's other things
such as heat Maps as well but here at
certified group we find these two
formats for data analysis and comparison
strains to probably be the easiest to
look at and to understand
especially when conveying this to
customers it's easier to kind of look at
it in this regard so that they can see
clustering of different isolates from
different strains and they can also see
clustering
of different species even if you have
different species here as well
um so you know the main thing here is to
look at the clusters of isolates and
determine relatedness
and this is really that the main
component of that analysis component is
really being able to determine that
relatedness and determine if isolates
um you know are comparing to one another
and if they're related to one another
so this will help you then determine uh
things like if you have a Harbridge site
in your facility where you're getting
consistent sources of contamination
or if you're getting repeated
contamination over time from some
external source as well
so that's really the the power of this
and being able to determine where that
source of that organism is in your
process
so how does this help well as I
mentioned once you have that information
as to you know if there's a maybe a
source within a facility that's causing
this contamination or some sort of
external Source you can then go on the
hunt that's the fun thing to do with
this is to then go and find the hot
spots in your plant where that
contamination is harbored and help
eliminate those spots
um that could be you know pathogens it
could be spoilage organisms a whole lot
of different things I get called out
quite a bit to come help customers with
these issues they may say hey I've got
you know contamination problems and then
maybe we've used some sort of subtyping
Technology like the broker to help
narrow it down and say hey these are the
places to look at well then I'll go into
their facility and try to dig into their
equipment dig into their drains and
walls and all kinds of structural parts
of the plant and find out where this is
coming from and if we can actually
identify it then then they can actually
go ahead and fix it and clean it and
rectify it make sure that it doesn't
come back
um
some other uses for this are looking at
whether we have
relatedness of isolates when we have a
major contamination event so one other
type of facility we work with is beef
cattle slaughter facilities and they
have things called event dates and we'll
actually talk about that here in the
next few slides and give you a
case study where that actually occurred
but these are massive contamination
events and we want to be able to see if
these isolates are linked to each other
sometimes and so that can be very
helpful using the broker Ira biotyper to
be able to do that
um also we want to maybe look at whether
spoilage issues and final products are
originating from a particular raw
material and we don't want to have to
identify that organism either maybe we
want to be able to uh just know is the
same organism there and multiple
different Lots coming from different raw
materials and uh you know where did it
come from in that process and which raw
material contributed it so I've got some
case studies the next few slides where
we'll dig into each of these different
situations a little deeper and give you
some real life perspectives on how we
use the technology the broker
aerobiotyper to accomplish some of the
I guess challenges if you will that we
were presented in each one of these case
studies
all right so here's case study number
one
um so this one is actually uh we'll just
call it facility a they had multiple
listeria monocytogenes positives
in a Ready-to-Eat sliced deli meat
product
and on food contact surfaces from that
production line
uh
one thing to note is that all positive
product and product that had come into
contact with the positive and contact
surface have been destroyed because
their product was considered adulterated
the facility went ahead and destroyed
everything so they still had these
isolates to work with but wasn't going
to implicate any product or their
production facility
so they just wanted to figure out what
was going on
and they had stopped production on the
line until they could find a source and
so they wanted to determine if the
listeria monocotogenies that they found
on their product was the same as any of
the isolates that they found in their
production environment so that they
could go about eliminating the source of
this listeria monocytogenes that was
getting onto their product from this
production line
all the samples at this point in time
had already gone undergone cultural
confirmation and were identified as the
student monosetogenous so the purified
cultures that we had available from this
were already identified and were already
available so we didn't have to do any
sort of isolation or streaking
so we took these purified cultures and
then streaked them heavily onto tryptic
soyager plates to create Lawns incubated
those aerobically the 35 Celsius for 24
hours and obtain sufficient growth
and then went through the normal broker
IR biotype for protocol where we took
this growth and re-suspended it in the
broker biotyper tubes and then spotted
those suspensions onto the broker IR
biotyper targets allowed this to dry and
analyze them and after analysis we've
grouped all the isolates together into a
single project and performed cluster
analysis
so the output from the broker or
biotyper was really nice because it
allowed us to see that there were two
major clusters cluster 21 and cluster
13. isolates and cluster 21 were a b and
d
a was the product isolate and B and D
were environmental sponge samples from a
slicer and the conveyor that was
attached to that slicer so we were able
to quickly see that the slicer and the
conveyor that was associated with it
were related to the product isolate and
we're able to narrow it down to that
region of the production line
this also showed that isolate C
which was from an environmental sponge
sample of the utensil was not related to
the other three isolates so that was
also very helpful too with regard to the
process of elimination
So based on the data from the IRA
biotyper one was then able to determine
that the slicer was the main source of
the contamination of the ready to eat
finished deli meat product
and uh although environmental sponge
samples of utensils that were positive
for Listeria monocytogenes were also
thought to be a source of contamination
this data ruled it out
thus the client was actually able to
focus all their efforts on taking the
slicer out of commission cleaning it
really well and they were able to ensure
that it was ready to come back into the
service before the line was started up
again
after this there were no more product
positives for Listeria monocetogenes
this was a big success story
uh before using the IRA biotyper the
options for analysis would have been
pfte or ribo printer analysis and the
pfge runtime would have been 18 to 19
hours and at least one day to prepare so
the total analysis time would have been
at least two days in addition this pfte
results could have been tied to
regulatory databases
rivo printer analysis where they're
taking at least another eight hours to
complete and was much longer than the
time needed for Iowa biotyper so as we
mentioned this production line was down
so they needed to have results very
quickly so in this case the iro biotyper
was able to take those isolates quickly
get um
similarity analysis comparisons done
with them and be able and was able to
help the customer make a solution
to the issues that they were seeing with
refractive contamination so time is
money and food production and so this
one was actually able to help you out uh
very quickly with regard to time
the second uh study that was looked at
here the second case study was with
facility B we'll call them they
routinely test beef trim which is neat
destined to be used for ground beef free
coli 015787
and over the course of three days they
experienced 68 positive samples so as
you can imagine this caused them to be
and what we would call a high event
period or a very massive contamination
event normally e coli15787 positives are
only about 0.3 percent of all the
samples that are tested
um so that that is very low and this was
a very high percentage of positives so
facility being you that something went
drastically wrong in their process and
they knew that they needed to
troubleshoot it so
they want to actually know though if
these isolates were linked uh which
would suggest a common source before
they went through this troubleshooting
process
so just as in uh case study number one
we were very fortunate to already have
all of these uh isolates culturally
confirmed positive and they were
positive for e coli15787
and then we took these purified cultures
and went through the same process like
we did with those listeria
monositogenies isolates in case study
one to prepare them for analysis with
the broker IR biotyper
uh when we did the analysis uh with the
IR biotyper there were six distinct
clusters observed uh cluster 412 was the
largest with 61 isolates that were in it
uh cluster 408 only had two isolates and
then cluster 406 370
313-354 and 305 all had one eye salute a
piece
so at the end of the day these findings
suggested that 91 of the isolates
obtained during this High event period
were highly related to one another
because they were all in cluster 412.
and So based on this it was hypothesized
that a common piece of equipment such as
an inline fat analyzer was contaminated
and that this was leading to multiple
days of massive contamination events
with this customer
So based on these findings facility B
did an extensive cleaning of the
facility and they were able to resolve
the issue that caused the widespread
contamination it had no more days of
high-level positives after these
corrective actions were made
and so in the past the analysis of
strains like this would have to have
been done with the fge
um and that would have been much uh
slower to complete given the sheer
volume of isolates I mean this was a lot
of isolate 68 icelands that we would
have had to run through the FTE and only
12 isils can be run at a time on a shift
mapper that's used for pfte any chef
mapper run as we saw in the previous
case study takes at least 18 to 19 hours
including at least one day of
preparation before running thus this
could have taken us up to eight days to
get all these preparations and runs
completed
however by using the IR biotyper we were
able to run all 68 isolates within about
six hours and have them ready for
comparisons so that was exponentially
faster
and that throughput was very very much
appreciated by the customer
because it then allowed them to make
their correction corrective action
sooner and get back up and running then
uh very quickly thereafter
so the third case study we'll talk about
is with facility C we'll call them they
had been experiencing ongoing issues
with high aerobic plate counts in their
Blended cheese product and these were
causing the product to be out of
specification to become spoiled over
time so not a pathogen issue in this
case study this one was actually a
spoilage issue
so facility C wanting to determine the
source of these high aerobic plate
counts by tracing backward from the
finished product to individual
ingredients
they didn't want to know the species of
the organisms that were present though
so they did not have this product on
hold and it was of high risk of
triggering a recall if we found a
pathogen so the broker Ira biotyper with
its lack of speciation was an ideal
situation for them here to be able to
track whether this spoilage organism was
coming from a particular raw material
and then going through the process
so the customer then sent those samples
of nine different ingredients two in
process in process samples and a
finished product package that all had a
high microbial count
all these samples were then plated for
aerobic plate count testing and then We
examined these plates and picked up to
seven isolates of different morphologies
from each sample and streak those to
make lawn plates which were then used to
prepare suspensions for the broker eye
or biotyper we then went through the
standard protocol spotted the
suspensions onto the target plates
allowed us to dry analyze them and
looked at the cluster analysis as a
project again
uh 15 of the 22 clusters that we got out
of here had only one isolate so there
were some isolates in here that just
were not linked to anything else
uh two clusters actually showed that
different raw materials had the same
organism present this wasn't too
surprising because we had several
different cheeses that were raw
materials that were coming into this
Blended cheese product so the fact that
we had two different organisms and two
different raw materials not too
surprising
however we had four clusters
that had
um what certain raw materials they've
had the same organism present in them
along with various work in process
products so there were several raw
materials where the organisms were
actually getting into the work in
process samples
uh and then one cluster
we had actually showed that the same
organism was found in a raw material an
in-processed product and a finished
product sample so this was likely our
spoilage organism that was causing the
pro finished product spoilage problems
that was coming all the way through this
process and so we were able to then tie
it back to a certain raw material and
saw that it was able to survive as it
went through the unprocessed product and
then all the way to the finished product
so in conclusion analysis with the iro
biotyper was able to demonstrate that
certain organisms were present in
various raw materials
some of them that were present in
various raw materials and in-process
products and then some organisms were
present in particular this one that we
were just talking about were present uh
in in process or raw materials in
process products and in finished
products
and so through this analysis facility C
was actually able to determine that the
source of the spoilage organism that was
observed in the finished product was a
particular raw material this spoilage
organism was passing through that entire
process from the raw materials to work
and process samples to finished products
and they were postulating that this was
likely a Spore former that survived
heating because there was a lot of
heating done
um in this process and so that support
former was getting all the way to the
end and then growing out and creating
spoilage problems
uh before the Advent of the iro biotyper
this would not have been possible to
show that these various organisms that
we isolated from the samples were
related to one another without having to
do some sort of biochemical
identification process this could have
actually identified the species if we
did that and so that was not something
that the customer wanted to do here so
it was very nice that the IRA biotyper
was available to them to allow them to
compare these organisms to one another
without needing to biochemically
identify them and this is all simply
done by just determining the similarity
of the chemical compounds that were
present and being expressed in their
cell surface
and so this allowed one to determine
that they were related to one another
without actually needing to identify
their species and if one would have
identified the species one could then
have identified the pathogenic species
and that could have caused all that
product to be implicated in the recall
which the customer did not want so this
was a perfect solution for them to be
able to figure out this challenge
without getting themselves into any kind
of regulatory Problems by doing the
analysis
so our last case study is with facility
B which is an ice cream manufacturer
that does routine monitoring for
Listeria species in their processing
environment
they also perform confirmation up to the
point of a listeria-like organism on a
plate
and so they wanted to actually begin
subtyping these listeria-like organisms
to be able to determine if they have one
strain or if they have multiple strains
and they also wanted to be able to
observe their contamination patterns
however they could not know which
listeria species these isolates were in
order to again avoid a recall situation
because the product that they had
produced was done while they had been
collecting these isolates and they
didn't want to implicate a new product
so we actually had uh isolates for
modified Oxford auger or MOX auger
plates
which were a typical listeria-like
organisms but they had not been
biochemically identified to the species
level they sent these isolates on plates
and these were frozen for banking at our
facility
at these various intervals isolates were
streaked to from these Frozen cultures
to tryptic soyager plates in order to
create wands and then we went through
the normal uh process of getting those
prepared for the broker Ira biotyper as
we mentioned in the previous case
studies
so over time listeria-like organisms
from this facility were grouped into
five different clusters these
represented five different strains that
were present in the facility
the largest cluster of these was cluster
184 that had 19 isolates in it followed
by cluster 182 with eight isolates uh
and the presence of these two clusters
demonstrated that there were two major
resonant strengths that had taken up
Harbor Bridge in the facility over time
cluster 164 cluster 146 uh each had two
isolates cluster 167 only had one
isolate so these were all presumed to be
some uh probably transient strains uh
more or less definitely not as
persistent as those two strains that
were represented by cluster 184 and
cluster 182.
so with this information a customer was
then able to plot all this subtyping
information on top of their positive
results that they were seeing with their
routine monitoring and were able to find
some of the issues that they were having
in contamination patterns that they were
seeing over time
so facility D actually took their
positive Point data from their
environmental monitoring software I wish
they'd get through us which I mentioned
is the the Emma program
they actually printed this off and then
added the subtyping information on top
of their positive spots on their Maps
this then allowed them to be able to
better visualize the distribution of
each strain throughout the facility
and so over time they kept doing this
and kept adding these isolates to their
database and we're using this to
determine whether a new positive result
was due to a new strain being introduced
into the facility or if these were or if
a new positive was due to one of the two
resonant strains that were in their
facility
in the past this really could not have
been done without identifying the
species of this listeria-like organism
uh that we were actually analyzing and
so ribo printer analysis uh actually
would have identified the species based
on the pattern assignment and so this
was really ideal for this facility to be
to continue tracking their strains
without determining the species and
implicating the new products using the
IR biotyper
so those were four different case
studies of how we have used the
technology in the past but we also do
see some future possibilities for how we
will use the technology going forward
one of the things that our team will
continue to do day in day out is to use
this on routine analysis of isolates
that come in and need to be subtyped in
order to determine if they are similar
or not I mean that's what we're
currently using it for right now we're
going to continue using it for that
however over time we would also like to
do things such as developing a database
of salmonella stereotypes and E coli o
groups to actually maybe potentially
provide a rapid serotyping library for
each of these isolates if one desires to
rapidly determine the exact zero type
grouping of the organism and do it
pretty quickly that would be nice
because you know we see a lot of things
the similar cell surface structures
between certain serotypes and we would
be able to group something in here
without having to use a lot of anti-sera
and doing a lot of extensive
agglutination testing to be able to
figure out what serotype it is
uh we also would be able to possibly do
side-by-side studies with banks of
isolates that have already been
subjected to whole genome sequencing in
order to determine the script
discriminatory power of the broker IR
biotyper as compared to the gold
standard microbial subtygiene method
whole genome sequencing we'd also like
to understand that and how those two
relate to each other
we also have thought about potentially
using this technology in a research
setting to see a different chemical
structures on the exterior of the
organism change over time that being the
same organism and seeing if they change
over time if they're subjected to
different conditions such as stressors
chemicals growth rate Etc
so that may actually alter some of that
surface chemistry and that would also be
kind of neat to be able to know if that
same sort of uh response is seen uh when
those conditions are applied to
different organisms or strains and
seeing if they have some sort of a shift
in their chemical structure too again a
purely research oriented type of
situation here but might be useful in
that regard as well but again like we
said the main reason for using the the
technology is to continue to do that
routine analysis on those isolates and
compare them to one another to see if
they're similar or not
so again I thank you for sitting through
the presentation today uh you know
hopefully we can answer some questions
for you all after this if you have any
and always please feel free to reach out
to me I'm very happy to always discuss
this technology and uh answer any
questions that anybody may have about it